boole cat podcast
this guy just in our interview said he
was the John Moran of the rap game
so we're going to find out about that
right now
Skillet baby freestyle Detroit's finest
in the building let's get to it
damn I gotta push this [ __ ] up huh
[Music]
people ain't believing me but God did my
mama should have named me airport cause
I'm a fly kid always giving back but
never talk about what I did gotta know
this [ __ ] forever if you're trying to
lock in people say I'm top 10 but they
say I'm not 10 came a long way from boo
lyrics but I'm not here my friends Pass
New The Rock I got the high hand and I
had the roxans and Roxanne I'm not
playing my Ops either got shot or got a
shot friend riding with my Drake if I
get stopped I know it's God's plan I'm
in
huh
shout out to Boolean kids there it is
appreciate y'all having me on this show
Skillet baby boom
hey we just ended a freestyle uh shout
out to our family at LRG you'll see the
new LRG you know Ewing athletic collab
go to lrg's website right now
l-r-g.com and use the promo code bootleg
and you'll save 30 off at checkout
that's a serious amount of money to save
especially during the holidays shout out
to LRG we got another freestyle dropping
[ __ ] maybe this week definitely next
week though let's go